[Applaudissements]
si je suis aujourd'hui ici si on partie
grâce à un monsieur vole mars
un prof african air biographie que j'ai
eu l'occasion de rencontrer en afrique
du sud pendant le mondial du bac
mais si vous le marin passionné pour
cette matic
il a su partager ce qu'ils savaient il a
su nous partager aimé partager cette
passion pour la géologie et
l'environnement en général
mais alors revenons à tout petit peu en
arrière je vous emmène en argentine mon
pays d'origine de ces petit accent qui
nous fait entendre pendant mon tacle
lavage messi est dirigée naturellement
vers les sciences naturelles et j'ai
fait mes études en biologie
après l'obtention de mon diplôme ma
mettre des stages il m'a dit de faire
une thèse en france je me suis dit
pourquoi pas trois ans ça va vite c'est
passé je vais connaître notre pays et de
notre culture parler une autre langue
que jusqu'à 6 moment là je comprenais
pas du tout d'ailleurs je me suis
embarqué ont marqué pour étudier les
taux et tendances de marque et d'arsenic
dans les sédiments dallas qui continue
dans le centre de l'argentine dans les
derniers siècles
je vous ai pas je ne vous inquiétez pas
j'ai failli perdre un aussi bon après ma
thèse était de de l'alchimie avec un
composantes changement climatique
tout ça c'est très beau mais je vais pas
vous parler juste odessa je vais vous
parler aussi d'un projet que j'ai
l'opportunité des grands donné et qui
est aussi un super projet il s'appelle
acclimaté en 2011 le conseil régional dé
l'ancien région aquitaine a demandé à
hervé le treut climatologue très connu
pour ses travaux des riens groupe est un
des chercheurs pour faire un rapport sur
les impacts du changement climatique en
aquitaine pour mieux comprendre ses
impacts sur la région et les façons de
mieux s'adapter c'est assez
changement mais le trust anciens du giec
a remis à leurs un groupe de chercheurs
qu à la fois eux mêmes ils sont réunis
une dizaine de chercheurs travaillant
tous de façon bénévole
mais qu'est ce que c'est logique le giec
c'est le groupe intergouvernemental
d'experts sur le climat il été créé en
1988 par les nations-unies et réunit du
1500 chercheurs qui travaillent sur le
l'évolution du climat tout par tout le
monde on fait sens d'un rapport
pluridisciplinaire il y en a eu cinq
depuis le début et il se base surtout
des des activités scientifiques de mon
entier mais revenons alors bloqué à mon
c ur glocal qui travaillent plus ou
moins comme le giec a réuni 170
chercheurs qui travaillent de façon
bénévole et qui sont étudiées x en faire
un rapport qui s'appelle les impacts du
changement climatique en aquitaine ce
rapport et des scissions décision des
élus mais aussi il est con but d éduquer
la population par exemple ce rapport
nous montre que les poissons migrent
vers les leurs dans les eaux plus
froides
donc les poissons qui empêche
aujourd'hui donne aux côtes
on le verra plus d'ici quelques années
mais qu'est-ce qui s'est il passé en
2015 ringot passionne territoriales qui
a fêté trois régions fonctions et
deviennent la nouvelle aquitaine la
région la plus grande et france pour que
vous ayez une petite comparaison effet
de la taille de la suisse donc des
environnements très variés qui vont des
des zones humides qui passe par le
littoral mais aussi des massifs
montagneux comme les pyrénées et le
massif central
toutes ces spécificités entraîne des
problématiques très diverses et très
variées comme par exemple politique
économique sociologique juridique
donc pour cette région un nouveau
rapport était fait et 240 personnes ont
participé aussi des façons de bénévoles
entre coordinateur électeurs rédacteurs
et plus de 200 organismes
on était investi aussi pour vous ce
rapport entre centre de recherche
université bureau d'études pour faire un
rapport qui s'appelle anticiper les
changements climatiques aux nouvelles
aquitaine pour réagir dans les
territoires et son rapport a été publié
cette année à la rochelle mais vous
dirait quelles sont les différences
entre le premier et le deuxième rapport
bon d'abord c'est pouvoir faire un état
des lieux décide si vaste région mais
aussi pouvoir parler des nouvelles
thématiques comme par exemple la partie
sur l'énergie la partition le territoire
sur la mémoire soit la partie juridique
mais aussi de la participation et
l'appropriation citoyenne
ceci est très importante parce que pour
pouvoir mettre en place des mesures
d'adaptation politique dans notre
territoire
il faut aussi pouvoir prendre en compte
le savoir des acteurs et des citoyens
ce rapport aussi est important pour ces
rapports il y a quinze 15 chapitres qui
permet dé démontré des conclusions
adaptée au territoire comme par exemple
avec la nouvelle aquitaine monde où le
trait décote
donc c'est à dire qu'avant on
s'intéressait juste juste aux
problématiques d'érosion mais maintenant
c'est pâques et l'émotion mais aussi de
la smar sion
mais une autre problématique c'est aussi
on parle de la disponibilité des l'ont
peut-être vous connaissez ce graphique
que je me présente ici peut-être pas
mais c'est important d'aider s'est
rappelé qu'il ya trois types de douce
dans notre planète un grand parti on les
trouve dans les eaux gelées et glacée ou
l'autre partie qu'on ne voit pas mais
qui sont nos pieds dans les nappes
souterraines
une autre partie convoi mais quand la
trouve de façon fluide
par exemple dans les fleuves dans les
lacs dans les états mais que ça
représente 0 25% de leurs disponible
presque rien pour cette disponibilité
assez réduite des lots il faut
considérer l'eau qu'on finit limitée et
unique et le changement climatique il
est où bon les changements climatiques
il vient ajouter une couche de plus en
créant une problématique
hydroclimatiques qu'est ce que je veux
dire avec selah bon que le cycle
hydrologique
il va être encore plus perturbée par
exemple on aura des étiages c'est à dire
le débit minimum deux rivières qui sera
encore plus perturbée plus sévère et
plus long on aura aussi des
perturbations sur sur la consommation
parce que les débits des rivières dont
de diminuer entre 20 et 40 % donc des
coûts on aura un échange en pas notre
façon de consommer cette ressource
on aura une surexploitation de cette
ressource
oh non et comme troisième point je veux
juste dire que par exemple en 2003 avec
la canicule qui la france a subi un
degré d plus entraîné 1 26 % des plus de
consommation en ont donc imaginons d'ici
la fin du siècle si la température a
monté deux ou trois degrés de plus comme
le gie est dit si on off et son rien qui
on aura une consommation très très
importante au dos
donc ce qui est proposé par le rapport
d'un climat terrain cédé par les 2006
vric de mix hydrique c'est de voir les
les besoins en eau des tous les milieux
et tous les territoires pour pouvoir
donner nos solutions mais des solutions
qui permettent de mieux gérer cette
restauration non il faut plus parler des
améliorera le milieu urbain comme si les
dieux étaient déconnectés il faut
pouvoir parler avec les citoyens et
pouvoir faire des espaces des
discussions entre élus scientifiques et
citoyens
oui qu'on puisse parler d'une vraie
solidarité de partage et pouvoir ainsi
anticiper mieux le changement climatique
c'est exactement sur cet espace kelly
mattera vu travailler c'est pour ça que
une tournée régionale est en train
d'être organisées dans toute la nouvelle
aquitaine pour aller de ville en ville
et parler avec les acteurs du territoire
c'est aussi mon souhait qui nous
puissions prendre conscience de
l'importance qu'ils nous avons
concitoyens qui ne pouvons faire bouger
les choses
parce que pour pouvoir faire les choses
bougent r les choses il faut pouvoir
changer les idées et pouvoir parce que
c'est important de pouvoir influencer et
changer les idées il faut d'abord les
croient il est partagé
[Applaudissements]